des sabres des kimonos des figures
spectaculaires non vous n'êtes pas en
asie mais à guyancourt la nuit des arts
martiaux organisé tous les deux ans
fêtait ce samedi 30 mars à 14e édition
au gymnase des droits de l'homme donc
l'objectif c'est que nos associations
puissent montrer ce qu'elles font ce
qu'elles sont capables de faire toute
l'année et que le public s'ébahissent de
tout ça et puissent éventuellement
adhérer à une des associations cette
année six associations se sont produits
devant plusieurs centaines de
spectateurs pendant trois heures et
demie
c'est toujours un bon moment de partage
et des changes ont déjà entre nous voilà
ça crée une émulation de créer un
spectacle vivant et original
et puis ça permet aussi de rencontrer
les autres associations d'arts martiaux
pour créer un spectacle original les
associations travaillent pendant
plusieurs mois sur les techniques
propres à leur sport mais également sur
la mise en scène de leurs démonstrations
se sont introduit le thème du jeu vidéo
on a essayé de le fusionner le judo avec
un jeu de combat avec toutes les phases
de tutorial d'eau training de technique
et de combat à la fin avec avec un père
et sa fille qui joue rj en parallèle du
spectacle visuel la soirée était
également pour la bonne cause
l'intégralité des recettes de
l'événement étaient reversés à la
boutique alimentaire balises qui rendez
vous dans deux ans pour une nouvelle
édition